we're looking at in one word maybe i
should say graphics not only those of
computer graphics or animation but the
enormously increased scope for pictures
for showing pictures for seeing pictures
seeing things singing seeing is a source
of wisdom and pleasure in a lot of ways
mankind really has no vocabulary to
discuss color because if you look at art
history until two generations ago nobody
knew what paintings looked like they
could be reproduced in black and white
going back to the 19th century before
then they couldn't be reproduced in any
way at all but until say the 1930s 40s
50s and in the 20th century there is no
way to you could say Titian is a great
colorist or Velazquez has extraordinary
subtle Browns or or the reason the the
13th century class at shark is unique is
because of the blue the special blue but
you couldn't see it I mean these say you
have got to travel to France or or two
to you know Venice to see take wherever
and not only that but once you were
there you know unless you stayed you
know you're going to say planet in front
of a picture in a museum and and nor are
you going to you know camp out in the
cathedral but computers have not only
made printing if not only made dis
falling on their screens but they made
printing on paper color printing vastly
better inexpensive the possibility that
we now have of seeing what what mankind
has done the art that has been done the
cities that have been built the
landscapes that have drawn people is a
tremendously exciting and to see each
other because ultimately that's what
people want to see most of all is other
people that's that's exciting opens up a
new world that man
and has longed for ever since he's seen
colors are good and I want to make my
world colorful and I want to see my
fellow human beings and I want to build
things and I want I don't want their
horizons to be further than what i can
see from my front door